I will sprint down I think there's just
for my soccer background growing up when
guys score goal they did sprint the
other way I mean I was going I saw
Patrick and then I wanted to embrace him
but I'm like no I he can't get hurt and
then Tyreke was you know encouraging me
to go to the Enzo and jump in with the
fans and that was a lot of fun Harrison
but Kerr after the game-winning field
goal that gave the Chiefs the victory
snapping a three game home losing streak
the 44 yarder after he'd made a 54 yard
or earlier in the quarter to tie the
game those patch for homes out there
running around celebrating if you're
watching it on NBCSN and look Chris all
that said great great effort by but go
down the stretch yeah great effort by
Matt Moore and the offense to get the
ball in position for the two field goals
the one that Todd the one that won but
but the table was set for the Vikings to
win the game up by three points with 748
to go ball on their own 28 a breakdown
of offensive play calling yeah called
for a pass on the first snap misfired to
see J Hamm here it is here and I just
you know pressure in a you know every
time Kirk Cousins did that roll out
there was location him yes they were so
we showed the first play incomplete
second play was a run third play another
run and they have to punt and look
Tyreke he'll was back there Britton
Colquitt had a nice punt that pinned him
at the sideline didn't match ants to
return it but then the Chiefs drive the
ball down the field they get the field
goal to tie the game from 94 yards right
the Vikings get the ball back with 2
minutes and 30 seconds to play yeah and
they could get nothing going another
incomplete pass first out a seven-yard
loss on a completion on second down
right third down no chance Punnett shank
short field Chiefs win it's that simple
now the Vikings defense stepped up and
had a couple big plays couple of sacks
and Matt Moore a couple of fumbles right
the Vikings weren't able to recover but
you know you give the Chiefs another
chance they have Travis Kelce they have
Tyree kill they had second and 21 after
that sack that seemed to drive them out
of field goal range right but boom
Kelsey boom Hill yeah 44 yard field goal
range and and it's just I've seen this
movie
many times with birth dozens at the
Vikings quarterback yeah and and I look
let me go back to that first row yeah
okay they throw the pass on first down
incomplete they run it on
second and everybody knows who runs
coming on second and ten that's the old
john madden thing play callers who dial
up a pass on first down and it goes
incomplete almost always run on second
down
so it's certain thirteen why don't you
trust in Kirk Cousins in that spot to
throw the ball instead of going with the
droplet well you'd like to you're right
I mean in that moment you know you're
paying them that kind of money and he
has a quarterback that's had a hot hand
lately like let's be aggressive and go
for the win now you know we've talked
about the Vikings formula we know it
runs through Dalvin cook right you've
heard me say it's not like the most
complicated formula in the world it's
run the ball dominate the line of
scrimmage that way gets the bootlegs
it's the play actions take some big
shots I think we both have had a little
concerns and I know I do when I just
watch film where they're a drop back
pass offense I don't sit there and go
wow this is really creative and this is
I've never seen stuff like this so the
Chiefs who air once again I would just
like to hit this hammer this home it's
the third week in a row I've really
liked what their defenses has shown on
the field you know that and then Chris
Jones being back changes them up from
Chris Jones he's in the conversation
from one of the best D lineman at all
football so when he's out there he's a
game wrecker and how many times
yesterday we look up a go man Chris
Jones holy cow Chris Jones he has to
play up a whole lot well and every time
Cousins did that bootleg it was Jones a
guy who thought that you're chasing him
it seemed like it was Jones every time
so I mean I gotta give Steve spagnolo
credit first of all their defense has
change if they lease are playing from a
position of power and aggressiveness now
before they were kind of sitting back
and like oh let's bend but don't break
and our guys will out score their guys
yeah okay not really I mean if you keep
bending and bending and then you know
your your your guys are on the sidelines
the whole time it's gonna be hard to
outscore them it's not easy that way so
I really give Andy Reid and Spagnola
little credit there and then your
Vikings defense is equally and you know
I don't want to just disappointing some
of the big plays they like 91-yard run
right over plated in the box effort and
then and then Anthony Harris got caught
flat-footed as it passes you know the
first touchdown pass post corner though
those type of things you know the other
big pass at the end of the game to get
him down a field goal range where it's
Trey Wayne's and and Tyree killed
one-on-one and he jumps up and makes a
pie like Tyreke
for a for a little small dude he is
unreal in these 5050 balls I mean it
helps when you have like a 50-inch
vertical but it was just I thought all
around him lost it helps when you have a
50-inch vertical and when you have the
speed to get to the spot while the guy
who's covering games is doing everything
he can to get okay keep up you're right
so he's under control the guy that's
covering him is like you're going above
his threshold the throttles like on red
it's like whoa we're not used to going
this fast yeah you know so but but but
either way it was a gutsy tough win for
Kansas City I really think Kansas City
without in my homes the last few week
few weeks don't go skip bayless saw me
know this is going to help their team in
the long run it's just gonna make their
defense tougher they've shown a little
semblance of a run game and you know we
talked about unpro football I mean on
profile bucks son you know football
night in America last night the the fact
that they're like oh they've changed a
few things in their past game let's but
let's block it up and let's just let
Watkins and Tyree kill work and things
like that be another element that when
Patrick mahomes comes back defenses
aren't gonna like that they're gonna
whoa I don't like the shotgun and he
throws it everywhere but I really don't
like when they protect it up and like
mahomes gets to sit there and throw 70
yard lasers all over the guys who were
gonna get open I don't have time to do
it so it might be one of those things
where it really works in their best
interests at Tennessee next week there
will be a question whether or not
mahomes plays the people who've been
trying to peg his return date have been
pointing to that at the chargers was
always regarded as the more realistic
that's in Mexico week 11 week 12 by week
13 Raiders then at the Patriots Broncos
at the Bears and the Chargers winnable
games down the stretch for the Chiefs
and that was a huge one because every
other team in the division won yesterday
if they had lost that they'd have been
in trouble and for the Vikings it was a
blown opportunity because if the Vikings
had managed to win they would have moved
to 7 & 2 they'd be tied with the Packers
and they'd have some separation with the
Lions and the Bears so look the Vikings
get another chance yeah to not win in a
big spot six days from now when they go
to Dallas for Sunday Night Football and
if the narrative holds they will lose
that game well I can tell you right now
they will lose they got to figure
something out and we know their offense
or
to the run game and when they can't run
the football then it takes away another
part of their offenses those bootlegs
that we talked about and they didn't
have either one yesterday and that hurt
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports